personnage comme ça il ya déjà un
problème de micro ben c'est comme
toucher
non c'est vrai c'est ses impôts mais un
peu magnifique donc entre entre huit
heures du soir et 7h du matin et après
c'est plus à ebrah vie à cette amère non
samuel ça va ça va ouais
ça la transférant ce moment toi ça va
des coutelas ya patrick mille olivia
bonamy
françois berléand olivia cattan et kenza
brigade laurent baffie ça ne surprendra
pas et amel bent tu connais mail bent
les y passe des coups de fil à côte
discutant
cette chanson quand même
aller où oui
c'est un jeu qui s'appelle moussa pas
fini encore on était persuadés qu'ils
étaient
vraiment mais oui bien sûr je suis allé
je te dis à samedi chez les anglais en
quart il a toujours son plus de merde
la vie aussi c'est aussi le tabac et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux